it is a terrifying constant thunder
explosions booming across this coastal
city
it's been going on for hours now
and this is a population in shock they
just stop and stand traumatized by a war
they did not start and do not want
in the distance artillery rains down on
ukrainian positions
the defense of the outskirts may not
last long
some families grab what they can this
little girl carries her bucket and spate
there have already been attacks on
civilian areas this place targeted by
rockets presumably to terrorize the
population happened about half an hour
ago
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
the front lines are over in that
direction
there is a huge amount of destruction
here and people are worried there could
be another salvo at any time
you see all the broken glass and
brickwork down here this is where this
man lives
jacob shows me inside his house
it's been wrecked
his great-grandson was hit by shrapnel
as he slept
there are still signs of life in the
city center but this is not normal
they're trying to get supplies
no one here knows when the russians will
arrive but they can hear the fighting is
getting closer
there is a feeling of absolute dread in
this city over the last five minutes
we've heard the sound a very intense
artillery barrages on the outskirts
now some people are coming out they
you can hear it there
they're queuing at this atm for money
they're also stocking up on supplies at
the supermarket
checking their phones calling their
relatives really worried about what is
going to happen next
in the queue waiting patiently we find
margarita
she's frightened but defiant
ukrainian forces are trying to fight
setting up positions now inside the city
but as we filmed the war felt very close
with bombs dropping families hunker down
in damp and gloomy basements
they don't know when this storm of fire
will
pass lude miller a mother of two still
can't understand why russia wants to
destroy her country
ukraine is a nation of suffering the
next hours will be filled with misery
and fear
as people cower in the dark from
vladimir putin's war machine
alex rossi sky news
mario paul